Speaker 1: David, I've noticed that the term
gaslighting now seems to be used too much.
Has it become problematic or even meaningless?
Yeah, this is this is a good question.
What's going on with the term gaslighting
is similar to what went on with Regressive
left a few years ago.
And I'll explain what I mean by that.
Gaslighting is when you manipulate someone
to get them to question their own sanity or
whether they can even trust just the most
basic facts.
They thought they believed it.
Sort of like, you know, you have very mundane
level.
You ask your significant other never to wear
shoes in the house 50 times, and then they
wear shoes in the house.
And then they you say, you know, I we've talked
about this so many times and they say we haven't
talked about it.
When one was that I don't remember.
Right.
Just like we did we did.
I imagine the 50 conversations, just a mundane
example.
But it can happen with a whole bunch of other
issues, political, social, cultural, et cetera,
that we are seeing something happen with the
term gaslighting that similar to regressive
left, there was a very, very short period.
And we talked about this in a long form piece
about the progressive left where the term
regressive left really meant someone who is
ostensibly on the left, but who is failing
to really do it.
For example, sometimes a self-described leftist
will support very authoritarian policy or
authoritarian elected officials or world leaders.
And we would say this is this is regressive
left in the sense that they claim to be left,
but they're really just authoritarian.
OK, yeah, it had some kind of meaning there.
It became a catchall for people who we disagree
with, and it was used by the right and by
the left, and it became essentially meaningless.
I stopped using it.
I used it very, very briefly to describe a
very specific thing.
Racism is another one where there's this trend
that we're starting to see, where someone
will identify something they believe is racist.
They will be called racist for noticing it.
Sometimes you will hear this from the right.
Well, they will say you noticing race so much.
Is a sign that you are the racist and a very
similar dynamic is happening now with gaslighting,
if you say something is gaslighting, you will
sometimes be called the gas lighter.
You will say your gaslighting people.
By claiming that gaslighting is taking place,
you are manipulating you were virtue signaling
by using that term.
And a very, very similar kind of vicious circle
starts.
And it does devalue the term in a significant
way.
So I think there is still value, you know,
regressive left is now in the trash as a term.
I still think that gaslighting has value and
there is still real objective empirical meaning
that is useful to us in describing, you know,
there was a lot of gaslighting by the Trumpy
and right.
About just telling people what your Trump
said, what you are seeing and hearing.
You cannot believe that's a form of gaslighting.
And I think it still has value.
But they're making every effort to devalue
it, calling it calling the use of the term
an actual gaslight in and of itself.
And all of these terms have a shelf life.
That's the that's the reality.
So let me know your experiences with the term,
either using it or having it used on you or
having it used merely to muddle up conversations.
We have a great bonus show for you today.
It arguably is the best bonus show in the
last twenty four hours.
From what I've heard from Pat, it's a very
good one.
Get instant access by becoming a member at
Join Pakman Dotcom or get on my newsletter,
because Monday, Memorial Day, we are doing
a one day membership special.
We are just blowing membership's out of here.
We're going to just be dumping huge amounts
of memberships at a really low rate.
It's going to be like a cash cow.
It's a loss leader, as the retail giants would
say.
Just get on my mailing list at David Pakman
Dotcom and then you will be notified on Memorial
Day.
You'll know how to get this membership special.
It'll be a beautiful thing.
And before you know it, you'll be joining
Unidentified: us on the bonus check.